i i won't i won't skip the step because
i'm going to miss something so i'm just
going to write down the terms
that
haven't canceled
on both sides
okay now look at this line for me okay
this line here
uh not knowing anything else about what
this actually means right what can i do
to make this much much better like
straight away look at it kevin
divided by x
y
everything factors into y squared
right everything every single term
okay
so here's what i'm going to do and i
just want to take note of it okay
i'm going to divide through everything
by
y squared
as you'll see later on um y squared
sorry this is gonna be really crucial
okay so just watch for it so what you
end up with
this time i'm gonna divide through and
then i'll collect my like terms end up
with this
okay
so i divided through by y squared that's
why for instance this 6y4 and 9y to the
4 became 6y squared 9y squared and
that's why
my minus 6 gives me the three okay now
what five three one three divide through
by three
uh sorry that's two
now
what's this starting to look like
right now okay i divided this through by
three right so it's going to be minus
three i'm going to kick it over the
other side
to see what kind of circle it is what am
i going to do
i'm going to complete the square so what
do i add
what do i add on this side
halve it square it halve it square it
you have that oh right which becomes one
that you square that
so if i add one there i add one here
now i can factorize yeah so the y
squared is just hanging out on its own
and this turns into
and the radius is
you're like for real after all that now
here's the thing here's the really
interesting thing what what is this okay
let's come back to our diagram okay and
this is a circle
i need to go a bit further
it has radius 2
and its center is at minus one zero
minus one zero so that's um over here
isn't it
okay now if it's radius two
the furthest it goes is over here see
how that's two units there so you're
looking like something like this sorry
that's terrible but you have the idea
okay so actually my p is a bit off it
shouldn't really mean it's not accurate
right
but p can move anywhere there okay
now by the way we're not done we're not
done
the
how old are you again
six
now
the circle is not just enough right
i miss something there's something
missing it's not just the circle
do you remember conveniently
i divided through
right i divided through now think about
what that does if i gave you something
else like say oh i don't know x x minus
1
equals
5x
okay and if you divide it through by x
in this case right
uh you could get a true solution for
that but we lost the solution namely
x equals zero right so in the same way
i've lost the solution here
namely y equals zero now y equals zero
what kind of line is that
straight
that's this line isn't it
y equals zero is the x-axis isn't it
now why do we need that line
it's the circle and that's straight line
why is the line important because it's
also
correct because it also occurs right
because if you've got a straight line
there then bpo is just a straight line
so how are you going to bisect it well
you just have to be on the line right on
the line itself that is okay now here's
the thing
i finished that i was like really
really
i was very skeptical uh especially after
all of this i'm like did i just want it
to be nice and neat so here's what i did
let's see if i can
stay is that far enough we'll see in a
second it's supposed to be okay
let's see what we get let's go be
further
oh no i might be a victim of software
counterfeiting that's not nice
okay so this is what i drew basically
okay
here's my a and my b
there's the um the moving point okay and
there's the origin okay now you can see
actually that does kind of look legit
right the red line
does kind of look like it bisects the
blue angle doesn't it it's kind of close
okay so to prove it
because this is my circle right
let's um let's let's watch it move shall
we
okay
do you buy it does it work wait wait for
it to get all the way around
okay
wait does
unfortunately i couldn't get that but
i'm just animating the circle at the
moment it doesn't look does it look
right does this angle or do these angles
always look equal yeah it works right
there
so
um that's really frustrating yeah
trouble you just get boring yeah exactly
right um now here's here's what's left
okay here's what i um haven't been able
to um finish
um usually when you go from here's a
geometric rule and then you get some
kind of equation right like um
like that okay you get your equation out
and then you look at it and you're like
oh geometrically of course it makes
sense like for example when i said okay
such as such a point it moves so the
distances are always the same between
these two points right and you get the
perpendicular bisector and then you draw
it and you're like oh obviously it makes
sense right
um you can prove it by triangle
congruence if you lie okay
but this thing i don't know why it works
um i don't have an explanation yet i
don't know why you you draw this if you
like uh what you know is radius two okay
um there's my center okay so you know
there's one unit there one unit here two
units there okay knowing that amount of
information
can you prove or can you show why
this angle is always equal to this angle
okay i've been sort of scratching my
head over it for most of um this morning
and um i i'm really stuck i can't see
any similarity or conduits
i don't know what to work with to show
that these angles are equal i think it
has something to do with circle
properties because you know it's a
circle so you've got to use that fact
somehow
i just don't know how to use it yes
so yeah
yeah not yet
i'm still i still want to let it turn
around
um i i don't want to ask other people
yet if i can solve it myself because
then the insight might arrive but i'm
going to pose it to you guys to see if
you can come up with your own solution
if you can see some insight that i'm
missing okay
but um yeah
i think
i think it's a really interesting
question so
there you go
hypnotized no
it's not quite going fast enough to
hypnotize you maybe it's by um
yes
there you go
okay so that's that's it that's the
question so victor i hope you're
satisfied